-Oh, I heard you missed us.
We're back.
It has been too long.
Five months. I love you guys.
I missed everything here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, I miss it all.
It was a long time.
Higgins, what were you up
to these five months?
-I went to prison.
[ Laughter ]
-Roots, what'd you do?
-We were in prison, too.
-Yeah.
It's good to see you.
I spent a lot of time at home
really is what I did.
I was with the kids
all the time, so much.
And this is --
Maybe this is a true story.
So, I was leaving today
at breakfast. I go, "I'm going."
"Where are you going?" I go,
"Daddy's going back to work."
And they just started
applauding.
[ Laughter ]
I got a two-minute
standing ovation
like I was at
the Venice Film Festival.
[ Laughter ]
I swear. They really did.
I go, "Wow, was I
that annoying?"
But actually, I started a
podcast in the five months
with the other hosts.
[ Cheers and applause ]
The other late-night hosts,
we started a podcast,
and all the money
went to our crew and staff
who were out of work.
And it was called
Strike Force Five.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I really -- I really want
to thank Jimmy Kimmel,
Stephen Colbert,
John Oliver,
and our upstairs neighbor,
Seth Meyers.
They're just fantastic guys.
And I know them
and I'm friendly with them.
But, you know,
I would say after this,
I'm friends with them.
And really, and they were
just great friends
and great people to talk to.
And it's a fun podcast
if you want to listen to it.
But we all get assigned
different shows, right, to host.
And so I hosted an episode
called -- It was episode five.
It was like a "Newlywed Game"
type of thing where --
because we're all married
to great, great women
and they must be going
through the same craziness
that we all, you know,
we have a lot in common.
So I did it through text.
You know, I texted them
the questions and stuff,
and it just was a disaster.
[ Laughter ]
Like I said, like, "When did you
first fall in love?"
And so they were like --
they answered -- some answered
for what they thought
their husband would say,
and then some
of the hosts were like,
"So are we guessing
what they're guessing
we would say?"
I go, "I don't know.
I just texted them
these questions."
So I don't really know
the rules of the game.
It changed a lot,
but you get to know everybody
and it's good to see
that side of them
and the human side
of the talk show host
that we know
and see all the jokes,
but got to really get
in there and talk to them.
They're all smart
and great entertainers
and great comedians.
But I had a lot of time,
five months,
a lot of time to really just sit
and think, you know?
And I just finally
just took a moment
and I just realized
how grateful I am
for all of this
and for this show.
I really love it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I really --
I really love this job.
I love doing it.
I love telling jokes.
I love interviewing people.
I love making you laugh.
I'm very lucky
to have this show.
And I want to thank you all
for supporting and choosing
to have me
in your bedrooms at nighttime.
[ Laughter and applause ]
This is what I love to do
and I want to do it
for a long time.
I'm so happy to be back.
Thank you to our crew,
our staff.
Our writers
are now back in the building
and we're going to make
some fun shows.
[ Cheers and applause ]